we are asked to evaluate the expression
5 to the x power minus 3 to the x power
for x equals 2. so pause this video and
see if you can figure out what hap what
does this expression equal when x equals
2. all right now let's work through this
together so what we want to do is
everywhere we see an x we want to
replace it with a 2. so this expression
for x equals 2 would be
5 to the second power
minus 3 to the second power
well what's that going to be equal to
well 5 to the second power that's the
same thing as 5 times 5
and then from that we are going to
subtract
3 times three
three times three and now order of
operations would tell us to do the
multiplication or do the exponents first
which is this multiplication but just to
make it clear i'll put some parentheses
here and this is going to be equal to 5
times 5 is 25
minus
which is equal to
plus 25 minus 9 it is equal to 16. so
that's what that expression equals 4x
equals 2.
let's do another example
so now
we are asked
what is the value of y squared minus x
to the fourth when y is equal to 9 and x
equals 2. so once again pause this video
and see if you can evaluate that
all right so here we are
we have variables as the bases as
opposed to being the exponents and we
have two different variables but all we
have to do is wherever we see a y we
substitute it with a 9 and wherever we
see an x we substitute it with a 2. so y
squared is going to be the same thing as
squared
minus
x which is 2 that minus looks a bit
funny let me see so this is going to be
9 squared minus x which is 2
2 to the
fourth power now what is this going to
be equal to
well 9 squared is 9 times 9. so this
whole thing is going to be equal to
81. this whole thing right over here is
9 times 9. 9 times 9 is that right over
there
and then from that we're going to
subtract
2 to the 4th power well what's 2 to the
4th power that is 2 times 2 times 2
times 2
so this is going to be 2 times 2 is 4 4
times 2 is 8 8 times 2 is 16. so it's 81
minus 16. now what is that going to be
equal to let's see 81 minus 6 is 75 and
then minus another 10 is going to be 65
so there you have it y squared minus x
to the fourth when y is equal to 9 and x
equals 2 is equal to 65 and we're done